why do you get depressed after you
accomplish a goal you celebrate a goal
for five minutes and then you're sad why
is that it's because you had the wrong
goal your goal should not be to climb to
the top of the mountain because the only
spot left is to go down your goal should
be to climb forever you never stop
climbing you're on a mission you're
trying to save the world stop asking
when can I stop you don't you don't want
to you want to climb forever you don't
want to stop not now not ever because
you are on a mission so one of my
biggest fears is the Aging rock star I
look at some of these rock stars who
made it big when they're in their 20s or
30s and then as they get into their 40s
50s sometimes even 60s they're still
playing which is great they're still on
tour which is awesome but what are the
songs that they're singing the songs
that they're singing are still the ones
that they came up with when they're in
their 20s or 30s and I can't imagine
that I can't imagine coming up with a
video in my 20s if I'm still showing
that video all the time if I'm still
showing my 40th video then that's the
one that hit I just feel like is such a
letdown I'm terrified of that I don't
want that to be me I don't want to think
of the video that I made last year is my
best video ever and all I'm gonna do for
the rest of my life is just play that
same video over and over and over and
over again I want to climb forever I
want to challenge myself to come up with
new stories each time whenever possible
making these kind of videos I want to
always push the envelope I want to
always discover new formats and when I
always look at splitting up my Channel
or bringing them all back together or
launching a course always always
something new always climbing I don't
see it as this Mountaintop there is no
mountain top me motivation watch the top
10 with believe Nation hey it's Nina
Carmichael we made this video because
you are the most ambitious person in
your circle you know you are capable of
more and you get that Push by surround
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan Carmichael and my take on his top
10 rules for Success enjoy
you're on the staircase and you're
climbing forever and you're never gonna
get to the top you don't want to get to
the top that's that's sadness that's
despair when you've accomplished
everything there is to accomplish you
hate your life that sucks you celebrate
this is what happens for high Achievers
right you celebrate for five minutes
like man we did it and then it's a big
letdown when I crossed 2 million
subscribers on my YouTube channel a
million subscribers I didn't want to
celebrate like because the day-to-day is
a celebration because this is I'd rather
this is celebration this making this
video right here this is my celebration
moment the process the actual part of
climbing right I'm trying to get better
every single time 6 000 videos later
still going when do I stop I don't I
want to make 6 million videos right my
goal of hitting a billion entrepreneurs
I don't actually want to hit a billion
entrepreneurs
I want to have a goal so big that I
never do it
and so I don't want to be that Asian
rock star I hope that when I'm 95 years
old
I may you know not have my mind totally
there my body might be giving up on me
but I'm hoping I'm hoping that I'm still
trying to push the envelope still trying
to do more do my best and maybe if I get
lazy complacent slow if I start
complaining you catch me complaining
when I'm 95 years old show me this video
back show me this video and say look
look you've become what you said you
didn't want to become right hold me
accountable I think as soon as you stop
growing you're dying
and I think that's why so many people
are unhappy because they've actually
stopped growing a long time ago
and so don't be the Asian rock star I
don't want it for me I don't want it for
you either room number two loose
scarcity mindset you are staying small
because you're afraid you're afraid of
the worst case scenario coming true
losing having no money and being
embarrassed but you know you're capable
of more you know the way that you're
going about doing things right now is
nothing compared to what you're capable
of unless you lose that scarcity mindset
you're always gonna stay small knowing
that you are capable of more today I'm
going to show you how so one of the
easiest ways to get out of your scarcity
mindset is to go from idea to action as
soon as you get an idea you do something
about it and sometimes that idea often
that idea is going to be too big too
scary too crazy you can't do it who are
you to do this you don't have the money
resources time connections energy right
all of that all of the excuses that come
into your head I like to teach myself
that as soon as I get an idea I go do
something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust them go do something rule
number three chase down your goals
they do but they don't have the courage
and confidence to chase it down if you
don't know who you are and what you want
then that needs to be your immediate
priority that's the single most
important exercise that you can do right
now if you know what you want but you're
not chasing after it having more
confidence in who you are will give you
the courage to chase it down either way
I'm going to give you the answers in
this video so when I first started
making videos
I sucked you can go back you can watch
the first one it was April 2009 over 10
years ago I sucked I was nervous I was
shy I was trying to memorize lines I was
sitting down I was in a suit I was
sweating I sucked it was brutal
and making videos
isn't a logical choice for someone like
me I was introverted I still am I was
afraid of being in front of the camera
I'm looking into the lens and the red
light went on and I went blank I was
trying to memorize my lines just on
paper if you saw me and you said what I
was good at and then put me in in a
situation where I'm making videos that
don't do that that's not for you here's
the thing I liked it
I wasn't good at it but I liked it and
when you like something with enough
effort enough practice most things you
can be great at it
now I'm still on my journey I still have
a long way to go there's still people I
look up to guys like Gary who are
crushing it and say I still have my
journey to get better on but I'm a lot
better than I was when I started
and now I'm off doing keynote speeches
and I'm getting flown out and getting
paid to speak in front of audiences and
I'm growing a Channel with 2 million
subscribers and then these sub channels
on top of them it's crazy
because I was doing a thing that on
paper I wasn't supposed to be good at
but I just loved it and that's where the
self-awareness piece comes in
because you will get an idea to go off
and try something but you'll judge the
idea and you'll say I can't do this
because I don't have X and Y and Z and
I'm not good enough and tall enough and
smart enough for whatever enough right
I'm not enough
and then you play Smile for life and you
have uncertainty and you're walking on
quicksand and you end up being pulled
into making somebody else's dreams come
true instead of you actually chasing
your own version of your life down
because you're thinking about all the
reasons why you're not going to win
instead of the eight while you will so
take it from me a guy who's introverted
afraid of camera shy
doesn't like talking to people
if I can get here so can you on your
dreams Rule Number Four
spend time with
Rick I'm always reminding myself of how
awesome I am of uh the ideas that I have
are great and I need to start acting on
them I'm very aware of my thoughts my
feelings my emotions and whenever it's
not feeling right
I switch
and I'll switch on a dime
as soon as as soon as this YouTube
channel stops feeling worth it
not fun anymore wrong energy I'm out and
I'll just leave it behind I move on and
go do something else
I think the same thing of of meditation
I haven't
been able to maintain
and find Value in a meditation practice
because I think there's two there's two
sides of meditation and I only recently
learned the difference
the first is about focus and presence
I'm always focused like I'm almost
always focusing presence I'm I'm 85 in
the moment focused and and 15 thinking
about the future and zero percent
thinking backwards
somebody asked me that question how much
time do you spend past present future in
your day-to-day like zero about the past
that's why I have a poor memory Mark
Drager says I have a poor memory
um I don't I just don't live in the past
so I don't remember most things because
they don't matter to me
I don't they don't apply to me I'm not
I'm not thinking about even even when
you ask me how old I am I have to think
about the year
who cares
I was born in 1980.
May 20th 1980. how was that relevant
because you want to compare your journey
to mine that I've come so this far 39
and you made it this far at 24 or 54 or
whatever I don't know I just don't think
that way I think zero going backwards
and then most of the time it's present
and and a little bit future Forward
Thinking
whenever I'm feeling
stuck I'll spend more time with myself
I'll if I feel like I need to go for a
walk I'll go for a walk
it's just paying attention to feelings
another conversation I get into with
Mark constantly is I don't remember what
I said but I remember how I felt
and that's mostly where I live just in
the lands of feelings and constantly
talking to myself also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five and take action
the reason why you are not chasing your
big dream is because you are afraid that
is going to fail you're afraid that it's
not gonna work and what people will say
about you and what you will think about
yourself but what's the alternative it's
sitting on your idea for years never
taking your shot because you're afraid
and living the rest of your life in
regret knowing that you had an
opportunity but were too afraid to take
it the way to not have regrets is to be
always taking action to as soon as I get
an idea go do something about it I had a
great podcast with my friend Mark
Drigger a couple weeks ago a month ago
or so where he was asking me about
regret and I used to always tell this
story of imagine you have a hangnail how
much that hurts and it's all you can
think about when you have a hangnail but
if somebody punches you in the arm you
don't feel the hangnail anymore because
you this hurts more right you focus on
what hurts more and suddenly this one
doesn't hurt as much that's how I would
use regret I would always think about
whatever pain that I'm in right now this
thing that I want to do that I'm afraid
it I would imagine that this thing is
going to be the best thing of all time
that this video I'm going to make this
feature I'm going to give this client
I'm going to meet is going to be the
best of all time and if I don't do it
I'm going to regret it for the rest of
my life for decades I'm gonna regret not
taking action and so the pain of doing
the thing is the Hang nail and the
future pain of regret for decades is the
punch to the arm and so it inflicts so
much pain on me that then I have to go
off and do that thing and I use that for
over a decade
over a decade that's the lens through
which I made decisions inside the world
but for the past two years I haven't
done that at all I haven't talked about
it I haven't done it for myself because
I talk about the things that I live and
I'm thinking why why don't I do that
anymore why don't I use future regret to
fuel me
and I found this because I'm always
taking action because as soon as I get
an idea I do something and so I don't
judge the idea I don't say why me I
don't Ponder on the idea I don't I don't
just default to strategizing the
thinking I don't think why did I come up
with this why am I thinking about this I
just do it you get an idea you go off
and do it and that's been my mindset for
the past year and a half two years and
as a result the Breakthrough was you
don't live with regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have you don't live with
regret you might regret some of the
things you end up doing but most of the
things that you regretting other things
done as the action's undone not undone
not taken the action is not taken you
don't regret the things that you did you
get the things that you didn't do that's
most people right there may be a couple
things that you regret that you did but
for the most part it's the things that
you are too afraid to do that you regret
for the rest of your life and so if
you're constantly doing if you're
constantly taking action if you're
always jumping then you don't have
regrets and it's been an interesting way
that I now see the world and hopefully
you can learn from as soon as you get an
idea you go off and you do something you
do that you won't have any regrets rule
number six concrete fear everything that
you want out of life is on the other
side of your biggest fears you want
something more you know you're capable
of something more you'll come up with a
great reason why you can't do that
something more but really you're just
afraid if you want to break through if
you want that dream life you need to
change the way you think about fear or
it will handicap you for the rest of
your life so my biggest fear is
disappointing people
I'm afraid that whatever I'm gonna do I
might disappoint somebody and that keeps
me plain small and so whenever I can
recognize it then I have to go all in
and do it just to show myself because it
allows you to play on a bigger stage
every time and that big fear you have is
still there it doesn't go away You're
Just capable of slaying a bigger dragon
each time so what used to count as
disappointed people in my fear of
disappointing people might have been
going to a coffee meeting and helping an
entrepreneur I remember one time super
clearly that I was booking a meme with
an entrepreneur and I was so worried
that I was going to disappoint her that
I was hoping that she would cancel and
the story told myself was I'm too busy I
got all the stuff to do you know the the
realistic reasons that you can convince
yourself right they weren't stupid
reasons they're realistic but deep down
was I'm just afraid I'm afraid that
she's gonna show up and I'm not gonna
give her value it's a deep fear
and then once I went to go meet her it
was amazing I remember sitting in my car
I was like wow like an hour and a half
ago I I was hoping that she was gonna
cancel on me and this is the greatest
thing of all time right your your
biggest fears
prevent you from living the life that
you want and so I'm afraid of
disappointing people most of the time
you can't catch I think we place them
all by default I think your greatest
fear owns you and is giving you tons of
logical reasons why I can't do that
thing but whenever you catch it whenever
you do watch a catch and say I think
this is just my fear talking
that means it's go time that means you
have to do it just to teach yourself
that you're able to conquer it and move
to a greater level of success rule
number seven be a
beer solving problems that's the core of
business someone has a problem you see a
solution they pay you to solve it if
you're not making money it's because you
haven't solved a big enough problem yet
so let's use my YouTube channels as an
example now we got so many YouTube
channels it's crazy
I saw a problem I saw a need right I
wanted visual content I wanted to learn
from successful entrepreneurs and I
wanted it done in a visual way I used to
read books a lot because books was the
only way that I was able to get this
information I didn't have mentors to
teach me about business right I had my
parents who were amazing who taught me
how to be a human but I didn't have any
face-to-face mentors that I can go to so
I went the books but I'm a visual
learner I'd much rather see it I get a
lot more by seeing Simon talk about a
message than by reading his book I just
do it's how I learn and I think a lot of
people are visual Learners and so it's
why I started my YouTube channel
I'm I started showcasing successful
stories I started sharing my stories
while in the process and has been that
Duality from the beginning of saying
here's what you can learn from
successful people and here's my message
as well so DJ plus thought leader mixed
together and here we go and and we've
had success
solves a problem because a lot of you
have the same problem my problem is your
problem you want more success around you
you want to be surrounded by these
people just like I did and instead of
you having to watch 40 hours of Simon
sign of content to find the best and
mush it together I do it for you I
actually didn't want to even have a
YouTube channel I didn't want to do this
I wish you did this if one of you did
this I would just subscribe be great be
free here we go amazing it was it didn't
exist it wasn't out there so I did it
and that's the process you could scratch
your own itch you could you can see what
problems other people have but success
in business comes from solving other
people's problems you subscribe to this
channel because you like the content
because you know hopefully hopefully
like the content it adds value to your
life it solves a problem it sets you up
for the day that's why I have this
morning espresso series of five times a
week Monday to Friday set you up for the
day give you the shot of energy
motivation plus ideas to help you go off
and build your business this is the
problem that I solve what's the big
problem that you solve rule number eight
trigger yourself for Success the trick
to getting yourself into action mode is
to trigger yourself for Success
triggering yourself for Success means
you've taken the decision making out of
it that as soon as you come up with an
idea you have trained Yourself by
default into action mode you see your
brain will always talk you down from
things because it's trying to keep you
safe and it only understands a world
that currently exists that is logical
and practical until you learn to trigger
yourself for Success you will constantly
doubt your thoughts your ideas and your
actions this video is gonna help so
today I want to talk about this bag
right here a lot of you leave comments
so newer fans of the channel say why is
Doritos sponsoring your videos Evan why
don't you have a healthier sponsor don't
you know what bad Doritos does to your
body you should be promoting healthy
living
Doritos is not a sponsor guys this is
the triggering me for Success every
single day and this isn't just some tiny
bag it looks small looking back here but
let me bring this up look at that this
is right next to my face look at how big
that baggage Rita's is
I have a strategy and it's a weird
strategy so maybe you'll love it maybe
you won't but I have a strategy called
Damn the Doritos I look at this bag so
I'm sitting this is how I'm working
right I'm not sitting I'm standing I'm
standing on a trampoline this is my
workspace right now right I'm standing
here I'm working in the corner of my eye
I got Steve Jobs up here and I got I got
this giant bag of Doritos all I want to
do is eat this bag all day long I want
to destroy this bag of Doritos
look at that giant ship oh
I'm gonna start drooling soon I love it
I want to eat that all day long
this bag is here as a reminder of how
great I am this is the mental
conversation inside my head Evan you're
awesome you're awesome for not eating
those Doritos every day and I want it as
a reminder people say it doesn't take a
lot of willpower
no it it builds for me at least builds
the willpower builds my strength every
time I see that bag of Doritos makes me
feel better about myself that I'm not
eating it and I have the strength to
keep going and so why I have that here
is when you're on a diet right this is
how it began when you're on a diet your
friends your family the experts will say
get rid of all the junk food from your
house get rid of it all because
otherwise you'll be tempted and then
you're gonna eat it and then you're
gonna ruin your diet I think that is
actually teaching yourself that you suck
you're teaching yourself I'm a weird
duck you're teaching yourself that you
are not strong enough to be around the
thing and so I need to get it out of my
environment the only way that I can
stick to this thing is if this other
stuff is nowhere close to me I think
you're telling yourself that you suck I
think it's a big crutch and just like
when you break your leg you have a
crutch your ultimate goal is to not have
a crutches to walk it's to run is to be
stronger than before right and so as a
step one maybe it's good right it's a
step one okay fine you broke your leg
you have a crutch you want to get on a
diet you're addicted to junk food get
out of the house awesome but as soon as
you go on vacation as soon as you go to
an office party as soon as you go to the
New Year's any kind of party you're
going to destroy the food because you've
trained yourself every day that you suck
that you're not capable I think you're a
genius I think you're stronger than you
think and so I tested it first with
myself and I thought you know what
Doritos are my Nemesis right I love
Doritos
oh my gosh she's looking at that bag so
I went to Costco and bought the giant
sized bag of Doritos I said I'm going to
put this on my desk all day long because
damn the Doritos because the Doritos are
stronger than me I don't think so right
I'm Evan Carmichael and same thing for
you
that thing that is holding you that's
that's stronger than you I don't think
so remember who you are remember how
strong you are and that's what this is
here for and it's been awesome to see
people now take this up a friend of the
channel uh LeRon was trying to get off
of sugar and he has this uh coffee cup
with a saucer and he drinks his morning
coffee and he put two packets of sugar
on the saucer right next to the coffee
so he pourses coffee has the sugar right
next to it and he just starts drinking
it and puts it down and looks at the
sugar packs and then just drinks the
coffee again and puts it down looks at
the sugar packs and his wife thinks he's
crazy and he's a little crazy too you
gotta be a little bit weird duck but but
I think this is actually how you build
your strength
Mark Drake another friend of the channel
is addicted to the peak friends cookies
you know the ones that have the the red
on the inside and the cream in the
middle those are among my favorites too
and so his Co when he heard this went
out and bought all these boxes of peak
frames and put it on Mark's desk and he
opened it up and this is one of my
favorite things to do when whenever I'm
around Doritos or something I really
love to to eat not just say oh put that
away from me don't be around me I can't
have that and not just look at it I want
to smell it
so Mark took these cookies brought it
right up here Peak free cookies right up
here
oh and you can just see the Joy on his
face Jess says he's bringing back
memories and just what those cookies are
gonna taste like when they enter his
stomach and just um goodness everywhere
right the smile on his face maybe a
little bit of drool coming out you just
oh
and then put the cookies down and walk
away
and how great that makes you feel as a
human to say here's one of my biggest
weaknesses of all time Bring It
I own you put it down and walk away
right I think that's how you actually
build strength by doing those difficult
things by triggering yourself for
Success every time I see the Doritos bag
I feel better about myself I feel
stronger about myself and I want you to
do the same thing if any of you are
gonna take on that kind of challenge I
want to hear you I want to follow you I
want to I want to see how your journey
is going because it can be one of the
biggest most important life-changing
decisions that you embark on rule number
nine get excuses out of your way most
people focus on the problem instead of
the solution and that is why they failed
I like to say that there are a million
reasons why your ideas will never work
out and only eight why they will either
way you're right so it's better to focus
on the eight Your Heroes the people that
you look up to the people that you love
and want to be like right Your Heroes
all succeeded with less than what you
currently have right now if they can all
do it so can you the only thing in your
way are your excuses so one of the
things that I love most about both my
wife and my team is that they're always
willing to find the way one of the
things that Nina loves most about
herself I had her fill out this form
maybe two years ago of like what do you
love most about yourself and at the top
was she's a fast learner she loves
learning new things she loves taking on
new challenges and I love that I love
that about her and I love that in people
I think you should be a fast learner I
think you should love learning I think
you should always be taking on New
Opportunities right now my YouTube
channel I've split up my channel into
eight or nine different channels and
then just recently I split them up again
where we launched a top 10 Channel just
for the top 10 videos so the top 10
videos aren't on my main Channel anymore
and uh then we're doing an everything
Channel where if you just want all the
content it's all on one spot so it's
chaos it's crazy my whole team has to be
restructured and everybody's taking on
new projects and responsibilities and
we're supposed to have a one month
transition phase to do it it that was
the recommendation that was that was the
aggressive recommendation does it have a
one month transition period and for me
one month just as death it's just death
I mean I said okay great one month but
then as I'm into it on the Tuesday of
like the first week like guys we need to
launch like this weekend
[Laughter]
all right
problems and yes we're gonna make so
many mistakes and people aren't trained
properly and there's more work and we
need to you know we figure out who wants
to do what and how so many issues
awesome let's go
I think about Rey for example on my team
who has been doing all these thumbnails
so I have a I have a set design for my
top 10 rules thumbnails that people love
and it's it's been going like that for
years and I've always been on my team to
say I don't care that everybody thinks
their thumbnails are great they can be
better how do we make them better and so
finally finally after years of testing
we finally found the format that would
win that would that would beat our
original thumbnails and there's minor
differences we zoom in on the face we
got rid of the second logo make the text
bigger minor differences and then Rey
has been going back and updating split
tests doing against our old videos and
we have 13 1400 different split tests on
my videos it's crazy I think I split
test more than anybody on YouTube so
he's going back and updating all the old
thumbnails
and trying to prove a winner each time
and he's maybe I don't know halfway
through he's like think about how many
videos we have on the channel we've got
6 000 videos a lot of them are our top
tens
now with this change I found a new
format
we found a new format a new thumbnail
different color scheme different text
different pictures
different logo new thumbnail format and
we found that it's working and so I said
Ray
I know you just changed all the
thumbnails
we gotta do it again it's like this is
so exciting let's go I love this guy so
much right where most people what are
they they're gonna complain they're
gonna say I just did all this work or
this other thing right
you don't want to be around people like
that and you definitely don't want to be
that for too many people the problem is
for so many people that's you that's not
even people around you that's you you're
thinking about all the sunk costs that
you put into something you're thinking
about invested so much into this thing
and and now you want me to shift
everything
yep
you need to be on the yep side now you
need to adopt that kind of mindset that
kind of personality that just because I
work before it doesn't mean it's going
to keep working you find something new
it's better let's go this is what the
whole game is about rule number 10 match
your ambition to your mission the number
one biggest thing that you are missing
is momentum you're a genius you've got
Michael Jordan level Talent you are the
best in the world at something but until
you match your effort to your
capabilities your dreams will never
happen so yesterday I had a young
preacher reach out to me on Instagram
young like early teenager reach out to
me on Instagram and say hey Evan I'm a
preacher I'm trying to get my career
going I want to make YouTube videos I
want to spread a message can you watch
my video and give me some feedback
and I love first off I love young
entrepreneurs who are going after it who
are not just sitting there making
excuses as to why they can't because
they don't come from the family they
don't have the right education you know
the right gear to make a video there's
this guy just takes out his phone
against a simple background poor
lighting doesn't matter right just takes
out his phone starts recording the video
and he's pretty good
right for for a kid who's 14 15 16 years
old he's pretty good he's way better
than I was he's way better than I was
when I started making videos at I don't
know when I started making videos 10
years ago how old am I now 39 29. he
he's better at 14 15 16 than I was at
29. that's amazing I love it but here's
the thing he was only making a video
once a week
and so he said I love it man but you
gotta you gotta match your actions to
your Ambitions you got to keep going if
you want to be the greatest preacher on
the planet you got to make more content
one to practice right if you're a Folly
if you're an expert if what you are
creating comes from here and you just
speak it out you need to be making a
video every day every day if you can
freestyle as an artist as a rapper you
should be making a video every single
day now if your videos require some
massive setup not because it's about the
quality of your thought but it's about
fancy stunts or something that requires
a lot more fine but if it's thought
leadership if it's content that's just
coming out of your head
right the quality of your ideas every
single day
once you get better the more you do it
the better you're gonna get took me 350
videos until I wasn't completely
embarrassed by my own content right I
couldn't watch it back because it was I
was too embarrassed but
now as I watch my videos it's funny
whatever Nina comes in and she's seeing
me watch my videos I always have this
big grin on my face like I'm I'm
cheering myself on I'm like yeah yeah
it's really good and it and there's
definitely still tons of room to improve
but it took me 350 videos before I
wasn't completely embarrassed so now I'm
6 000 or something videos in it's hard
to keep track
your actions have to map your Ambitions
so if that's you if you've got ideas
you've got knowledge stop coming up with
excuses and make the content film it and
post today and again tomorrow and again
the next day and again the next day and
when you're creating so much content one
again you're getting better because the
the quantity leads to the quality but
two you get less attached to one video
having to be the thing
so often you make one piece of content
one painting one song One video you make
it and then that has to be the thing
you're getting feedback and you're
destroyed if it doesn't take off if this
video doesn't take off great next
right next next next keep going keep
creating you need momentum
so your actions have to map to your
Ambitions right whatever idea you have
in your head you want to be the next
Oprah of whatever industry great
let's see it let's see it in the work
let's see the energy let's see it in the
output that you are creating every
single day
the fastest way to fulfillment is to
feel like the work you do matters at the
end of the day everybody is built to
serve and write a whole book on it you
are built to serve you want to feel like
today matters that you're going to wake
up and you're going to create something
today that will mean something to some
people to someone maybe it's a million
people maybe it's one person but you're
gonna make something that will mean
something to somebody look at me I'm
sitting here in a parking lot my wife is
shopping at a food store and I'm sitting
here in the car with my my dogs passing
out on my phone making a video why
because I feel like this matters
I feel like somebody's gonna watch this
video and it'll make a difference for
them and hopefully that's you maybe not
everybody but at least one person will
watch this video and it'll matter and
it'll mean something and
endless
and when I feel that I'm much more
likely to show up I have more
fulfillment I have more energy I have
more kindness I have more love I have
more motivation and when we feel like
what we're gonna do doesn't matter makes
no difference nobody cares if we show up
or not that's the path down to anxiety
and stress and overwhelm and depression
and suicide this is where most people
are most people do not like their lives
most people feel like what they do does
not matter
I think most people wake up and they
drive to a job that they hate
and they feel like today it doesn't
matter nobody cares if I show up or not
the work I'm doing doesn't really have
an impact and that's why a lot of people
move towards entrepreneurship is because
we're looking for more fulfillment
because we want to feel like this thing
we're gonna do is gonna make an impact
and at least somebody's life and if you
can run some of those things together
you can have a couple days even in a row
feeling like this matters
and the energy difference that that will
be inside you the motivation will change
the kindness will change how you show up
or others will change how you talk to
yourself will change all because you
feel like the work you're doing today
matters they did
functional MRIs on people's brains and I
talk about this and build this here they
did functional MRIs in people's brains
to see what parts of the brain light up
when we're helping people when we feel
like we're going to do something that's
even just a small act of kindness
and it lights up the same part of the
brain as having food and having sex
serving others
the same part of the brain is having
food and having sex
we're hardwired to do it if you're not
happy right now is because you feel like
you're not serving that you don't matter
you might be doing stuff that matters
but you feel like it doesn't matter this
is where I get stuck on goals people say
well what are your next goals I don't
know 5 million subscribers 10 million
subscribers it doesn't it doesn't
mean anything what does that mean
it's more the qualitative stuff that
means the most to me it's the comments
that you guys leave on the videos it's
the people that come up to me at events
and tell me how much the content has had
an impact on their lives like that's the
juice that's why we do what we do
and of course you have to get numbers
and of course you have to drive revenue
and of course you have to like all of
that matters because in making money it
allows you to go and create more and
serve more and help more you know build
a better life for yourself as well
um money is definitely important it's
got to be in your top five but it can't
be number one
number one is feeling that you're on a
mission
that you're going to make something
today that will matter so how do we do
it
again I go through the process and build
the serve but basically three steps it's
who I have so who is your single most
important core value and if you have to
guess what is your most important
program what do you stand for as a human
being
means belief so I want to spread belief
everywhere that I go in this video my
intention is to spread belief I want I
want to believe more in myself and I am
hoping that you believe more in yourself
as a result of being around the stuff
that I make I don't always accomplish it
but it's the intention it's the goal
always going in and whatever your most
important core value is that's what you
still need more for yourself it's your
biggest roadblock right now and it's
also the gift that you want to give to
the world to the people around you you
want to help them feel X as well for me
it's believed what is it for you step
two is your why and your why is your
purpose and your purpose comes from your
pain so whatever you struggled the most
with is the thing you want to help other
people through so I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur a young entrepreneur or
a 19 year 11 quit on my business partner
didn't think I was adding any value no
contribution not getting any results
working my face off but just getting
zero results no traction and I hated it
I hated it so I quit on my business
partner
I went back the next day but that was
that was
man the worst day of my life and
my why is to help other entrepreneurs
not struggle as much as I did whatever
you struggled with the most is a gift
because you're going to help other
people not struggle as much as you did
and that will make you feel amazing
forever we all love helping right back
to the functional MRIs you love helping
you love assisting you you'll you'll buy
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or you open the door for somebody
or you'll help somebody pack their car
with groceries or help somebody up who
fell on the street or something you'll
do that it'll you'll feel good but
that's a little momentary Thing versus
if you felt like
there's somebody who you're helping who
was a younger version of you you see you
in that person
and you help them come alive by talking
to you by spending five minutes with you
you see hope light up in their eyes that
wow maybe I don't have to stay stuck
maybe I don't have to struggle and
suffer as much as I am because they met
you
and that's a totally different vibe and
feeling that's that's the thing to get
addicted to get addicted to serving get
addicted to helping get it get addicted
to impacting you know what a difference
it makes and so figuring out your why
becomes really important because well
often
uh just find ways to
try to find any kind of meaning without
ever ever having done the deepest work
and as entrepreneurs we struggled often
looking back I don't think about my most
painful moment that was in the past I
don't want to touch that I want to be
happy not to miss it and move forward
well this is how you do it right the
point of looking back at your most
painful moment is not to live there it's
to say there's lots of people who right
now currently are struggling with the
thing that you struggled with before you
can help them and you'll you'll light up
you'll be the greatest thing of all time
to help those people so first is your
who your most important core value
second is your why which is your purpose
and the third is then your how and
that's that's your passion so how do you
want to help people so how so I want to
help
people believe in themselves and
especially entrepreneurs because that's
what that's where I struggled the most
but how do I do it well however you came
out of the hole that you were in is a
teachable thing that you can give to
other people so for me it was model and
success and that's it who has done this
before and I studied them and I applied
that lesson as Bill Gates applied his
lesson to my business and we started
having success now what have I done for
the past 20 years is teach people how
they can model success to the situations
in their business of their life to
accomplish their goals so how did you
get out of the hole that you were in
what was the thing that you did and
where we get trapped a lot is we love
helping people to get the result but we
don't love the process of helping them
so the classic example I use if you're
moving your your your office I love
helping you as an entrepreneur move to a
new office but I don't want to help you
pack boxes and pack up computers right
so I like the end result of helping you
believe in yourself and you've launched
your new
office awesome but I don't like the
process that leads up to it so we're
constantly chasing the result but we
don't enjoy the process we're the number
one rule for Success if you have to
enjoy the process and so we get givers
we get trapped in this Loop of
constantly helping people because we
love helping people we feel good helping
people and we get the result of helping
people but we don't enjoy the process
and so we never get actually great at
the thing or world class because we're
not enjoying the day-to-day work and so
that becomes the next challenge is
however you got out of the hole that you
were in is a teachable thing to others
and we have to enjoy the process of
doing it so it doesn't feel like work
write that whole expression of find what
you love and you'll never work a day in
your life it's true you know I I love
making videos how have I done so many
videos for so long so consistently
because it doesn't feel like work this
isn't this doesn't work I would you know
my wife is in in this store here you
know shopping for for food that feels
more like work than sitting here in the
car and making a video for you guys
right and so there's no right or wrong
you know for for my wife she'd probably
rather be in there than making videos so
for you what's the process that you
actually enjoy that is contributing to
other people so when you can combine all
those things when you can
find the thing you love doing that's a
service to others that is helping people
who currently are who you used to be in
injecting them with the core value that
you've got that you still need even more
for yourself that's when everything
starts to share so the who I help
process who who sing the most important
core value why your purpose your purpose
comes to your pain and how
is your passion how you actually want to
help people
with their you know through your who and
in your why you figure that out
everything gets easier everything gets
more exciting everything gets happier
everything you feel more grateful more
confident More Alive more momentum you
start making more money it's it's like
you're you stop fighting the world
and you start flowing with it
because you want to serve
and you've got so much kindness and
opportunity inside you that needs to
come out that where you are right now is
not is not where you want to be it's not
where if you fast forward a year two
years five years you want to be in a
better
spot
everything wise health-wise emotional
gratitude money in your bank account all
of it and it's and it's possible when
you can connect your who your why and
your how to find a fulfillment that
you're after treat yourself like you
matter
talk to yourself like you would your
best friends think about
think about how you talk to other people
you know think about if you're watching
this video if you're a fan of this
channel you are probably
pouring into so many people you're
giving them love you're giving them
encouragement you're giving them belief
you're telling them they can do anything
right your friends even Tech even
strangers on social media you're
probably telling them that they can do
things right you're believing in them
you're giving them confidence but then
what happens you go home you look in the
mirror and you're just telling yourself
all the reasons why you can't do
something that voice inside your own
head sucks right telling yourself that
you can't make it and someone like you
is never going to do it we don't treat
ourselves with the same level of
compassion empathy that we have
for other people you wouldn't talk to
your worst enemy the way that you talk
to yourself
and that's a big problem I think that
needs to shift that needs to change
because as long as you keep
talking to yourself
like you're a piece of garbage
then you're never going to accomplish
anything great
we have to start to shift it I had a
whole bunch of issues in how I talk to
myself
I used to say well I'm too shy I'm too
introvert I'm nobody's going to want to
hear my story my message doesn't matter
who am I to go off and do this I have to
have a huge ego even I'm sitting here
filming in a parking lot like I would I
would never do this only only people
with giant egos and
uh loud mouths would ever do that right
I'm still working to unwind all of that
but the more you can catch it
and the more you can shift it it allows
you to go off and do great things not
just for yourself but for other people
because if you fast forward
if the way you've been talking to
yourself for the past couple years
continues to be the way that you talk to
yourself for the rest of your life
nothing changes
so how do we shift how do we get to a
point where hey we're actually seeing
better things about ourselves number one
is you have to catch the voice you know
what is the negative voice what are you
saying to yourself because a lot of it
are just
it's not intentional
you know it's these automatic thoughts
it's a subconscious thoughts you come up
with an idea of what you can do and
immediately you shut yourself down
without even noticing it just it's a
default nature instantly boom no I can't
do that no you suck you can't do that
so what are the negative thoughts that
are coming up in your mind and just
trying to catch it
number two is whatever you want to have
more of you need to create that in your
life you need to create the habits and
routines to have more of it in your life
so for me I want more belief right and I
go through this whole process of how to
figure out your most important core
value or your one word you can pick up
your one word or build the serve it'll
walk you through it
what do you need more of in your life I
need more belief and as much as I'm
trying to spread that to the world with
the videos and everything I make I also
need more of it myself I need more
belief for myself and so what helps me
believe in myself well I try to design a
life and an environment to help bring
that out more so
everything from the outfit that I wear
you know I tell myself I'm a superhero
going to work this is my believe uniform
just like Batman puts on his costume
from what my office looks like and the
pictures on my wall I've got my parents
on my wall and
looking at them reminds me of the
message that my mom would always give me
that I'm Advocate Shirley Carmichael I
could do anything and believe that I can
the videos that I make the the main
channel the top 10 Channel this Channel
all the content that I make is designed
to help me believe in myself more
that's what helps me come alive
um service you know thinking about
how what I'm gonna do will have an
impact on somebody else besides me
helps me have the courage to go off and
Chase down the goals that I have for
myself so what is it that makes you come
alive what do you need more of it in
your life because you're probably not
getting enough of it
right the thing that you need more in
your life you're not you're not getting
enough of it right now that's why that
negative voice is so powerful and
default
so think about the people who you're
hanging around and the media you're
consuming all of it you're not getting
enough of the thing that you need so how
do you get more of that thing and
engineer it design it so that it's part
of your daily calendar that's not
randomly happening in your life but it's
with intent
must happen every day
so number one is catching that voice
what is that voice
number two is designing that environment
and the habits and the routines for
yourself so that you're around it
constantly you're changing our
environment to be around the thing that
you know that you want to be and then
number three is
Empower people to pull you out of the
Matrix you know Empower people to call
you out Empower people to give you
feedback
some of my favorite ways to do it
whenever I'm going to an event or
whatever I'm talking to somebody I
respect and I need some help input
guidance feedback I'll say tell me why I
suck remember I suck at this thing why
do I suck at this like how do I get
better
and when I do that it's because they
give me their honest feedback you know
when when you just ask for feedback
people will be afraid of hurting your
feelings and you won't get the full info
so I say tell me why I suck and they say
well you don't suck but
here's what you need to fix
I empower the people around me that if I
say scary difficult or hard
then I have to go up and do the thing
just because I said scary difficult to
heart I don't want to be the person who
plays small so my son particularly loves
this one right it's like that you did it
you said scary oh shoot okay now I have
to go up and do it what are your trigger
words what are the things that make you
stay small and then empower the people
around you to call you out on it so that
when you don't catch it because you
won't catch it most of the time you
won't catch it but when you can't catch
it and somebody else can
not being defensive and not uh
putting our guard up and realizing that
hey this behavior is keeping me stuck
empowering the people around you to give
you the feedback to pull you out of the
Matrix so you can start turning what
subconscious to conscious
if you feel like
you're a little bit stuck
if you feel like
you know you want to do more and you're
capable of more and you want to serve
more and help more
and you know that you've got this voice
inside you that's keeping you there and
you're struggling with how do I get it
from subconscious and automatic negative
to subconscious and automatic positive
everything starts to change
you have to treat yourself like you
matter
just imagine that you were actually your
own best friend
just imagine that you came to you with
the problems that you're facing what
would you tell yourself
it's probably going to be something
loving something encouraging something
powerful something positive not the
words that you're actually using to talk
to yourself
this doesn't change in a day you know
doesn't change in an instant
it's a process
but if every day
by day you can slowly start to believe
in yourself more Empower yourself more
talk to yourself in a better way
you're going to create
a much better life for yourself and then
you can pay it forward and help others
because no matter what words you say no
matter how much you tell people to be
positive again you're here watching this
you are the most positive person you're
in your family you're pouring into other
people no matter how much words you use
what they'll be inspired by most is your
action
no matter how much you say hey love
yourself make this happen I believe in
you if they see you not believing in
yourself not taking the action you need
to take they'll never be inspired to do
it themselves either
they'll be most inspired by the actions
that you take when you're afraid and you
doubt yourself too it's time to make a
change let's make that change today if
you think money is scarce you hoard it
because you believe that no more money
will come to you
if you know money is abundant more money
will flow to you this isn't about being
wasteful doesn't it doesn't mean you
have to go and always empty your pockets
and buy a lot of dumb stuff and throw
away all your other stuff it doesn't
mean you have to waste your money
but it's switching the mindset of money
is not just some scarce thing that you
don't know how to make that you will
never have more of and so you need to
hoard every single dollar that you've
got
this is honestly something that I am
continuing to rewire myself on I
struggled a lot with money especially in
the early days of my business
um even growing up I grew up in a middle
class family my parents spent my parents
are behind me on the wall hold on there
we go this is me when I'm eight or nine
and my parents here they believed in
education a lot and they didn't have a
ton of money we weren't poor but they
spent all of their money basically on
putting the three of us kids I have two
sisters through private school so any
money that they made basically poured
into our education
and as a result we didn't have you know
money for other things and
um where my friends at these fancy
schools were getting you know BMWs for
their 16th birthday so they can go off
and drive uh you know I didn't get any
of that and it's not what was me but
it's more I just had a scarce mentality
around money in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I was eating
the same bean salad lunch every day
because it would fill me up and wasn't
very expensive
when we celebrated a win we'd go to
McDonald's if we got a new client like
hey we sold another piece of our
software we go to McDonald's and Order
large fries and share that between the
three of us because it was cheap and we
wanted just some little way to celebrate
and
I just remember how painful it was to
feel like you have no money and you
can't buy stuff and I couldn't hang out
with my friends and I couldn't do what I
wanted to do and I think that has a
traumatic effect you know I mean maybe
that's you as well you you have a
scarcity mindset around money that you
don't know how to make it and so
anything you've got you got to really
hold on to it and protect it
and again I'm not advocating for being
Reckless or stupid or just throwing
money away be smart about how you're
going to invest and use your money the
more important thing is developing the
mindset that you can
create money that by bringing a lot of
value to people you can make more money
you can turn it into something
so one of the things that I've done
recently that that has helped both
myself and Nina my wife is we create
what we call a care fund
and every month when we're doing our
numbers
Nina will put together how much we've
made this month how much cash flows come
in ETC and then we allocate a certain
percentage for a care fund that we have
to go off and spend
uh either for ourselves or for other
people
and so my default is to invest invest
invest invest invest right like invest
back into the business invest into into
into markets invest in the assets just
invest invest invest invest invest
invest
the and that's a good that's a great
good mindset the downside of that is you
don't get to see
the impact that it can create
and so said you know what we need to
dedicate a percentage every month to go
and help somebody else and maybe it's
help ourselves you know
um on the weekend Nina bought a very
expensive purse
we went shopping she had a very
offensive purse we bought a Chanel bag
and
probably more expensive than she's ever
bought a bag and for me it's like oh my
gosh you can't be spending this amount
of money on a bag
but it's worth celebrating yourself so
you know what like we earned that we did
so much work in our business you can you
can go and afford that
we've also used the money to donate the
Charities we've also used the money to
uh support our family and things that
they needed or wanted in their lives and
it's something that we have to spend
every month
Nina asked hey can we just save it so we
can invest more and then that leads to
more in the future like no we're already
saving other money to do that like that
has to be spent every month and so where
we have to sit this might sound crazy we
have to sit down every month and figure
out how we're going to spend this money
because my default is not to go and
spend the default is to invest or just
to save
and so doing that it doesn't have to be
a big amount of money it could it could
be a hundred bucks a month that you
force yourself to spend on making
somebody else's life better or even your
own like that thing that you would never
buy for yourself you know what I've
worked hard like I'm gonna buy it or
you're gonna go buy somebody a meal or
you're gonna go and give a homeless
person 100 right like you're gonna
you're gonna do something with it
because what it does it starts to change
your mentality around it it starts to
make you feel like
more will come
that I'm creating
and so whether it's 10 bucks 100 bucks a
thousand bucks 10 000 bucks like you
know whatever it is I'm not advocating
you go drain your bank account and just
go crazy and buy a Chanel bag you know
but allocating a certain percentage
every month
so that you can start to rewire your
beliefs around money that it's not just
super scarce so that would be step
number one right allocate some kind of
budget to helping especially others
because when you can when you help
others it just makes you feel so good
and you can help others in a lot of ways
you can help them with your time you can
help them with your expertise you can
help them you know not just give a man a
fish but teach them how to fish right
but there's there's the immediate
gratification of helping somebody buying
the coffee for the person behind you in
line or seeing somebody that you know
that that
25 bucks 100 bucks will make a big
difference and like you were able to
afford to do that
gives you the extra oomph to go off and
want to do more of it like if you know
that that 25 bucks change that person's
life imagine if you can give them 2500
bucks
but to do that you'd have to go off and
build a bigger business right so the the
core of your business needs to be
serving and helping and contributing
back and you can't afford yet to give
somebody 2500 bucks but you could if you
kept building your business and so it
just gives that little extra bit of
motivation and incentive right to get
out there and start to do it to allocate
a certain percentage second is to be
around people who are
who are generous be around the people
who have the mindset that you want to
have if there's a belief that you want
to adopt the fastest way to do it is to
be around the people who constantly are
screaming that belief the people who are
constantly living that belief so if you
love my view on something great hanging
around me more often there's lots of
videos you love Grant cardone's view or
garyvee's view or Oprah's view on
something the more you hang around them
and watch their content and read their
books and listen to their speeches the
more you're going to start to adopt that
same belief system
so if you want to believe that money is
not scarce then you need to be hanging
around people who believe that money is
not scarce because probably the people
in your life believe money is really
scarce and the people that I grew up
with believe that money is really scarce
the closest people around me and so it
doesn't mean you stop hanging out with
them but you need to inject new people
in even if it's just through YouTube
videos other people who believe the
thing that you want to believe because
otherwise you get pulled back down
because your environment has been
created to keep you where you are so if
you want to change where you are you
have to change the environment and it
used to be that you had to you have to
really change you had to go somewhere
else you had to move out you had to find
a mentor to hang out with and have
coffee with consistently now you can do
it through through YouTube I've been
inspired by tons of mentors who have
never met
because of the content that I've learned
from them on YouTube
but it takes the effort and intention to
be consistently around it that this is
the belief system that you want to have
you need to create that habit for
yourself from the things that are on the
wall to the clothes that you wear to the
media that you're consuming every day
being intentional with that to say it
this is this this is the belief system
that I want to have I recognize I'm not
there yet but this is this belief system
I want to have and I want to be around
the people who believe this to their
core because their belief in that thing
is stronger than your belief against it
and whoever's more confident wins
and so when you're around the people who
believe that thing so much they will
pull you towards them to start having
that similar belief system and then
everything starts to change
I think having a scarcity mindset is
extremely limiting
I've I've lived through really intense
versions of it I still feel like I'm
coming out of it I've grown a lot
compared to where I used to be but still
have a lot a long ways to go I probably
still have things
that I'm holding on to that I shouldn't
uh I probably still should be more
generous than I am
um and I'm I'm working through it as
well I might just be a little bit
further ahead on the curve definitely
compared to 19 year old Evan who thought
money was the most scarce thing in the
world
when you can learn to make that rewiring
happen that's how you start to change
your life
so if you look at the people around you
look at their beliefs especially around
money
and see what do they think and then see
where they're at in their life compared
to the people who have different beliefs
around money and where they're at who
would you rather be and you could be
there you could be that person
if you start to change your beliefs your
environment start to
help more people with it start to allow
the money to flow
because when you start to believe that
you can create a lot more money for
yourself
a lot of things start to change you've
got a great idea
you know it can change the world you
know it could have a big impact you know
it could change the fortunes of yourself
your family the people around you you've
got a great idea you know what can work
you know it can work
the problem is you don't know if it can
work for you you believe in the idea but
you don't believe in yourself and so
here's what's happened why well it's
because you've tried and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and you maybe saw a little bit
tiny results but then you lose the
motivation and and you stop you've never
stayed with anything long enough to
actually let it see results and so you
built up this pattern inside yourself
that says I can't do it the idea is
great but I can't do it that's really at
the core if you really believe that you
could do it and you really believed in
the idea you'd be doing it and crushing
it so it's the biggest difference is why
lack of belief is the world's biggest
problem the only thing you're missing is
actual sustained momentum against your
ideas because if you believe that you
could do it you'd be out there doing it
you believe in your idea
and how it could change the world but
you don't believe in your own abilities
to do it
now this is where we have to start
talking about making decisions with your
head versus your heart
so your head only understands a world
that exists your head is logical it's
practical and so whatever's been done
can be done again right it's logical and
so if you've got a job at some company
you know you can make X thousands of
dollars a year that's that's safe that's
logical that's practical you know it can
be done it exists other people have done
it too
you compound that with people telling
you to do the safe thing right go get a
job go take the safe path go take the
safe route and so there's a lot of
outside forces especially fear generated
that keep you on a small path keep you
on the safe path and it's not
necessarily wrong it's not malicious
they're not trying to hurt you
it's just fear-based and so it's small
you never create amazing things when
you're living in a fear-based state and
that's what you're doing when you make
big decisions with your head
because your head only understands a
practical world that currently exists
now your heart your heart's a different
story your heart can create something
that's ever existed before your heart is
where all the artists lives all the all
the game changers live all the people
who end up making massive change in the
world that's where they live they're
creating something new they say I see
something that other people don't see
and I can go create it that's heart
you're creating something that hasn't
existed before that doesn't make sense
that's not logical that's not practical
there's nothing to tell you that this
could work but you feel that it can work
that's where I know you guys are at if
you're watching this channel you're
watching this video that's where I know
you're at the problem is living inside
your head instead of living inside your
heart
so what happens is you'll have some days
where you're living in your heart you
have some days where you feel bold
motivated excited feeling like you're
capable like maybe you could actually do
this you'll have some days I'm gonna
switch my hand my hand's getting tired
I'm holding the video you'll have some
days where you'll actually feel that way
like maybe I can I can be the person I
am bold maybe you watch a video maybe
just wake up and you get inspired you
had a great dream something happens you
have this moment where you just feel
bold powerful and stopper and say
today's my day I'm gonna go off and do
it and crush it right we've all had
those moments
but then you wake up the next day and
you're back to being in your head
telling yourself I can't do this I
didn't go to school for this I don't
have the money for this I don't have the
talent for this I'm not good enough for
this I'm I'm not brave enough for
creatures enough for this right that's
all you're ahead talking to yourself
when you haven't fully decided
on something big what ends up happening
is you're heading your heart fight
so if you haven't fully decided that you
want to start this business that you
want to hit your 10 million subscribers
on YouTube that you want to fill in a
blank your big crazy ambitious goal when
you haven't fully decided on it your
head and your heart are going to fight
they should fight
because it's not logical it's not safe
it's not practical if it was it wouldn't
be a big idea your big amazing bold
ideas are not logical they're not
practical and they're not safe
as your head is always going to say whoa
whoa whoa slow down this is scary
and most of the time you're gonna listen
to your head and the people around you
will tell you listen to your head
what you need to do is fully decide what
you need to do is decide that this is
going to happen that it's not an option
anymore that there's no maybe I'll do it
maybe I won't your heart has to decide
the big decisions in your life treat you
go move to that other country or other
City should you go marry that person or
not should you go take that job or not
she should go start that business or not
big decisions with your heart and then
you use your head to help you figure out
the how
I always find it so funny when people
are thinking well should I do that
business or not or should I marry that
person or not and they make a they make
a list or make a checklist
and you write down pros and cons right
never make a decision that's big in your
life based off of objective pros and
cons because you're making it using the
wrong part of your body
because you might really love somebody
and you come with all these lists and
you got
80 80 cons on that list and only one pro
or maybe that one pro is all you need
same thing with the business there's a
million reasons why your business is not
going to work out you sit there and make
a list of of pros and cons there should
be way more cons there's a million
reasons why you're not going to win an 8
why you will and the people who go off
and win only focus on the eight
making a list of pros and cons to help
you make big decisions in life is one of
the stupidest things you can do
straight up
now your head is very important
your head
helps you accomplish your goals but only
once your heart's decided
so your heart allows you to make the big
decisions I want this to happen in my
life no negotiation this is going to
happen
and then from there you use your head to
figure out how to do it
right once your head is not fighting in
your heart once your head is understood
oh
he's serious she's serious okay crap how
do we actually make this happen now
that's when you use your head because
you're a smart person and you need your
head aligned to help you accomplish your
big goals so if I want to go off and
build my YouTube channel and get 10
million subscribers that's happening
when I first started YouTube 11 years
ago there was no educational content
there were no 15 minute videos on
YouTube it was it was all memes and and
stupid videos and cats and
not this not this at all
and it took me too long to listen to my
heart quite frankly you know I loved it
and so I kept doing it and and you know
part of my own back for myself was that
thankfully I kept going I wasn't as
consistent as I am now but I kept going
I didn't give up even though there were
no signs that I would have success right
my first video got three comments in one
year and one was my mom one was my
sister and one was some random dude I
wasn't getting traction I'll still
looking back at some of my old videos
yesterday and a lot of them no no
comments right like one video 35 views
zero comments
I can spend a lot of time making that
video
and so I kept going
because there was something inside me
that said I need to keep doing this
I wish I kept going faster and it's my
wish for you too right now with your
business with your idea with your crazy
goals I wish you keep going but I wish
you'd go faster on it that you decide
with your heart to say I am making this
happen
and you say head listen to me we're
making this happen now you're the smart
one help me figure out how to actually
do it so to get to my 10 million
subscribers how do I do it
and every day I'm using my brain to help
me do it and hopefully you are too
when you're heading your heart are
fighting when your goals your Ambitions
your dreams are fighting every day what
you think is practical logical possible
you're just gonna be stuck
very slow growth very some momentum
knowing you're capable of more but just
stuck because you're fighting yourself
the biggest problem is you're just
fighting yourself but when you can let
go when you can say my heart is going to
help me make the big decisions in my
life
and my head's gonna help me figure out
how magical things start to happen and
that's my wish for you your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
struggled the most with as a human being
is what you want to help other people
through for the rest of your life
something terrible happened to you you
know at some point in our lives
something terrible happened to me
happened to you nobody gets through this
life trauma free something terrible
happened to you and that terrible thing
will Define you in one of two ways
either that was negative and in that
story haunts you and holds you back and
and fills you with all these limited
beliefs or
you recognize that that thing that
happened to you is The Ultimate Gift in
that your purpose now becomes to help
other people not struggle the same way
that you did when you can transform that
giant pain that you had emotional pain
when you felt the most worthless as a
human being into something powerful and
positive because it's now not just about
you anymore it's about serving and
helping others who are like you
that's when everything changes my
purpose is to help entrepreneurs believe
in themselves more because the the worst
day of my life the worst moments in my
life for when I was in my first business
and I quit on my business partner and I
I had no belief I
I was down on myself I felt worthless I
felt I was working every day and just
nothing was working out and what do I do
what do I do and I I quit on my business
partner I quit because it was just too
much too much work too much stress too
much negative thoughts too much just
lack of self-worth not enough belief
and I woke up the next day and I and I
still I went back to work because I did
not want to live with the regret and I
actually had a voice of Oprah in my head
telling me just find a different way to
stand
it's not working out it's okay don't
quit just find a different way to stand
and I eventually made it through
we built the company sold it I've had
other successes but
the thing that fills me up forever is
helping other entrepreneurs who are
trying to believe in themselves because
that's back to who I was
and I still make the content for 19 year
old Evan because there are millions of
people out there right now who currently
are 19 year old Evan
and so
one of the most helpful things you can
do
is try to figure out a couple things one
what was that most painful moment like
how do we turn this into
practical a lot of entrepreneurs a lot
of you watching this channel you are
positive you are energetic you are
enthusiastic you are pouring into other
people you're probably the most
optimistic person most dream-filled
person in your circle and that's amazing
and that's a gift and you should keep
doing that and
you still have lots of moments where you
don't believe in yourself when you don't
have the courage that you need you don't
have the boldness that you need and and
we don't like looking backwards you
don't like look into the painful moments
the entrepreneurs ambitious positive
people is like I don't want to think
about all the negative things that
happen to me I want to go off and build
this thing I want to say stocking
negativity is that you can you relate
but it's important to think about that
most painful moment not to sit there and
live there and say oh woe is me but to
recognize
that there are millions of people right
now who currently are still struggling
with that thing that thing that you have
overcome even if you're not done growing
learning improving yet that thing that
you struggled with that you're coming
through many many many many many many
millions of people right now today are
struggling with that thing
and they need you they need your hope
they need your voice they need your
message you need your inspiration you
can reach those people in a way that
Evan Carmichael can't that Oprah Winfrey
can't that other people can't because
you experienced it
and I and Oprah have it
so step number one is to think about
what is that most painful moment
that you struggled through
that you wouldn't wish on anybody else
step number two then becomes well how
did you get out of it again you're not
done climbing but you're way better off
than you used to be it's funny how we
we criticize ourselves for not being
further ahead like I I should be up here
her followed that idea I'd be over here
by now all these other people are doing
all these amazing things and I'm still
feeling like I'm stuck okay
but also look at how far you've come
right you know you want to keep climbing
growing swimming Etc but you've come a
long way compared to who you used to be
and every now and then we need to pause
reflect Pat ourselves on the shoulders
say you know what I'm I'm way further
ahead Than I Used to Be
do you from five years ago or ten years
ago would look at the you today and say
holy cow I can't believe you've done
that
right Evan from 10 years ago who had I
don't know a thousand subscribers on his
YouTube channel would look to Evan now
and say oh my gosh that's crazy I can't
believe you did that even though right
now I'm thinking I gotta do more I got
to be better got to work harder gotta
gotta go faster gotta come with new
ideas I'm not pushing enough right if
you look back man there's been some
tremendous growth you've grown a lot
and so how did you how did you get out
of the hole that you were in how did you
stop struggling as much you probably
tried a million different things but
there's one or two or three things that
worked that's teachable
that's teachable to other people the
thing that saved me was modeling success
I looked at Bill Gates's story and I
modeled that for myself and my software
company then started to have success so
what have I taught for the past 20 plus
years now is how can other people model
success so how did you get out of the
hole that you were in
and then how can you then teach that to
other people
because they're struggling because all
of the tests and tries and attempts and
failures that you went through to find
the one two three things that worked you
can Now shortcut somebody else's path
this is what I think it means to max out
your Humanity this is what I what I
think it means to live in what Jonathan
Fields calls maximum sustainable
generosity it's like how can you keep
giving in a sustainable way
that fills you up because you don't want
to just do things for you humans are
built to serve it's wired inside you you
want to feel like you matter like today
matters like the work you're going to do
today is going to be meaningful to
somebody
and the people you love help the most
are the ones who are currently
struggling with the thing that you
struggled with
so figure out what that thing is that
most painful moment in your life that
you never want to go back to
and then how did you get out of the hole
now that is teachable
and then set number three is Having the
courage to share your story
I get it it's scary it's difficult it's
hard to put yourself out there to share
what you went through the struggles you
may be afraid of how you're going to be
judged or seen you know today you were
just a normal person and now tomorrow
you're going to put this out there now
now maybe you're you're scarred or
you're tarnished
but it's important because
by you staying silent it perpetuates the
Silence by you being afraid to share
your story everybody else who's
struggling with the same thing that
you're struggling with they feel afraid
too they feel like they don't belong
they feel like they're weird and not
accepted and not normal
by you putting out your story and what
you went through and are still going
through
it gives the permission to other people
to feel like they have somewhere that
they belong
that they are normal that they're going
to be okay too that they're not alone
so you share in your story I used to
really struggle with thinking well only
egotistical Maniacs share their story
and talk about themselves right it's
about serving well hold on
by you sharing your story is actually
serving you're not sharing your story
just to have the spotlight on you just
to say how amazing you are you're
sharing your story because you're hoping
that other people can see themselves in
you because your purpose comes from your
pain you're trying to reach the people
who currently are who you used to be
and in looking at you and hearing you
what you've come through and where you
are now that will serve as inspiration
for them to keep going
or for them to even get started or for
them to not take their life today
because they saw your video or they read
your book or they saw the post you put
on social media
sharing your story is not about you
sharing your stories about impacting
others and they can see themselves in
you where they can't see themselves in
Evan Carmichael or Oprah Winfrey or
insert you know whatever expert Guru or
entrepreneur
you have to figure out what that most
painful moment in your life was you have
to understand how you got out of the
hole because it's teachable and then you
have to share your story
you put the message out there
because your story will change
somebody's life ultimately your purpose
comes from your pain
you want to serve you want to help you
want to feel like today matters you want
to feel like when you show up to do the
thing that you're going to do today it's
going to have an impact maybe not on
millions of people's lives
but on at least one person's life if you
felt like today you were gonna touch in
a deeply meaningful profound way at
least one person's life
you're gonna show up totally differently
than if you felt like today doesn't
matter that nobody cares
and just forget about the day
I love you I want to see you win
let's make it happen get rid of your
10-year goals and create a mission
instead I think a lot of people are so
worried about where they're going to be
in a year and five years and 10 years we
do these goals planning actually you
ever gone through that you ever gone
through a goal planning exercise goals
said and exercise at events you read a
book says we're going to be in a year
and five years or ten years
and the more that I've thought about it
the more that I've gone through the
exercise is the more I realized it's not
important
that's not helpful it's not where we
want to be because you don't know what
you're capable of in a five-year period
a 10-year period think about who you
were five years ago take today's date
and subtract five years think about that
person
could you have predicted where you are
right now could the person you were five
years ago have any degree of confidence
is plan a life for who you are right now
this is like there's no way there's no
way not if you're growing not if you're
learning not if you're improving if
you're watching this channel then you're
somebody who is learning and growing and
improving and so you had no idea what
you're capable of five years ago and so
what makes you think that it's any
different now that you can plan for the
next five years the only way that you
can create a 10-year plan for yourself
is if you are not growing and you're in
a really static life you know like if
you're going to be a lawyer and you're
going to work your way up and be a
senior partner at the law firm and that
that takes a certain amount of time cool
you could you could plan that out
that's a pretty boring life
you know chances are if you're watching
this video you don't want that life that
you want to create new and build new and
that requires
being the being flexible to jump off of
your 10-year goals right it's not that
it's wrong to have goals goals can work
they can be motivating but
your goals right now a reflection of who
you currently are
that's the problem whatever goal you set
right now is a reflection of who you
currently are and the more that you are
growing as a human and the more that the
world involves the new technology comes
out and New Opportunities arise
the longer Horizon you put out the less
accurate it's going to be
and so instead of worrying about having
a 10-year goal replace it with a mission
the problem of a 10-year goal is you
could actually hit your 10-year goal
it's just way small compared to what
you're capable of
and so the answer is have a mission
what's your mission what are you trying
to accomplish like what's the big
problem that you're trying to solve and
then wake up every day trying to attack
that mission as opposed to worrying
about where you're going to be in 10
years this might flip a lot of goal
setting on its head that might flip a
lot of what you've been told or taught
or thought on its head and listen if
having that 10-year goal works for you
and is actually motivating cool keep
keep with it keep going if it's helping
you use it but if you feel like there's
something more or you feel like 10 year
goal is not enough you don't feel
motivated when you look at your 10-year
goal from two years ago it doesn't
appeal to you anymore it's probably why
you know you're you're growing too
quickly the problem is not your goals
the problems that you grew too much the
10-year goal is great for who you were
three years ago
you're not that person anymore you've
grown too much it's that's that's not a
reason to feel bad that's really feeling
amazing you know you've grown you've
outgrown yourself you've shed your skin
you now turn into the next generation of
you
and So my answer is admission what's the
mission what are you trying to
accomplish you know so for me I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
entrepreneurs and you know people don't
believe in themselves people don't
believe in themselves and I don't
believe myself enough you don't believe
in yourself enough nobody nobody you
know walking out here believes in
themselves enough we just we don't
believe in ourselves enough
and I want to I want to solve that
problem and I'm I'm never going to solve
that problem and I wake up every day
trying to solve that problem and why
it's so helpful to have a mission like
that is
because it gives you something to fight
for every day and there's always
something new that can come out that can
help you with that and there's always
opportunities that I think guys the
amount of things that I've seen and that
happened in the past 10 years if you
look at 10 years ago
where was I on YouTube I started in
April 2009 so I was early in on my
career on YouTube I had a couple hundred
subscribers there's no way I would have
said it'd be here there's no way just
with the with the impact I've had with
the people I've met with the even just
the confidence to sit here guys I would
have been so terrified to sit in a park
making a video
terrified of who's watching me who's
judging me who's coming around the
corner who's behind there maybe you know
looking at me and judging me you know
they've been it's would have been
impossible so the person I was 10 years
ago would have never even thought of
this as a possibility
and now it's it's it's normal
it's not a problem
right how quickly that we can grow
and so you can with a mission what's the
problem you're trying to solve and then
as you develop new skill sets and
improve mindsets and better belief
systems and as you know the mark and the
technology evolves and opportunities
arise as you keep going and building
momentum there will be new things that
you can go off and do that you never
thought were possible but it's always in
service of the mission
so how do you find the mission well
that's your purpose for me and your
purpose comes from your pain so whatever
you struggled the most with is the thing
you want to help other people through
and so I struggled so much to believe in
myself in the early days of my business
and quit like I quit for one day on my
business in worst day of my life and I
just want to make the path a little bit
easier for others how do I keep going
people ask me how do you how do you keep
going how do you keep making content
have you made I don't know thirteen
thousand fifteen thousand I don't know
how many videos I've made it's crazy how
many videos we've done
I only slept two and a half hours last
night it was a really rough night why
get up and keep making content because
I'm on a mission
because this means something to me
whether four people watch this video or
four million people watch this video
I'm hoping that
this video in some way is a video that
moves a needle just a little bit for
somebody watching maybe it's you maybe
this is the video that you decide I'm
gonna I'm gonna do something I'm gonna
find my mission I'm gonna stop creating
10-year goals and stop over planning
over preparing and overthinking and over
strategizing and over doubting myself
and just go do something like maybe
today this is the video or maybe I make
another video today that accomplishes
that like that's that's my goal that's
why I do what I do that's what gives me
the energy to wake up when
every bone in my body is saying you know
sleep
don't do the difficult thing
and it's easy because I'm on a mission
and so what's yours what did you
struggle with the most as a human
and if you can connect to that
you can think about all the people who
currently are struggling with the thing
that you struggled with
you know you're not done growing you're
not done learning you're still improving
there's still a long ways to go you're
by no means perfect neither am I
but you're a lot further ahead than you
used to be and there's a lot of people
right now who are right now stuck where
you used to be
I didn't know what to do they don't know
where to turn they don't have anybody
who believes in them they don't have any
hope they don't have any strategies they
think they're stocked they think they're
stuck in your story your message your
content you reaching out you could make
the difference for them
if you actually believe that it's going
to just change the energy with which you
show up and open you up to amazing new
opportunities that again you can't
predict 10 years in advance
so it's a it's a challenge it's a call
to action today
if you love setting your 10-year goals
and it works for you amazing keep going
do do what works for you but if you feel
like
you're judging yourself against them if
you feel like they're not working for
you if you feel like you're six months
in and you already want to change it the
problem is not that it's a 10-year goal
the problem is that you have already
outgrown what what you're capable of
you've already outgrown it six months in
a year and
and the thing that you won't outgrow is
the mission
to have a have a goal have a purpose so
big
that you never solve it and you wake up
every day trying to solve it
[Music]
yo I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there if you quit on something too soon
that you still love you will regret it
for the rest of your life if you don't
love it anymore quit move on you will
never win doing work that you hate but
if you love it